surprised and chilly in the bathtub yay
work baby I just wanna drink you [ __ ]
myself
this is a thirsty thirsty time so it's
great that you ever drink your hand okay
alright what's up y'all this is where I
get my long time because we're in the
middle of nowhere in Montana on a ranch
and this is my bathtub in our cabin I
didn't want to take a bath I just wanted
a drink today okay fine today Thirsty
Thursday I'm drinking bay leaves this is
my mama's favorite drink she ordered
this she orders a double in the rocks
and then she starts giggling like a
hyena it's hilarious you know that laugh
it'll start being like a I do it too and
I laugh or two so mom and this one's for
you okay so what are we doing today well
tell everybody what's been going on the
ranch um we've been having calves
weren't oh my gosh we had a red a little
red one born
Ulric was so cute we had a big old boy
born a bull and he had was cute
what if they come and they have a white
face is that is there like a defaulting
a Baldy no it's just rude but okay he
was huge
like I can't believe that thing came out
of a cow that thing was huge
I'm just saying cheers to that cow
that's really I mean and rivers been
taken you've been given her horseback
riding lesson she's taking a couple more
spare driving lessons with you which
makes me nervous which is why I'm also
drinking but it's fine just because I
fell off the horse and bent my tailbone
perpendicular to my spine and now every
time I sit like those long voice days in
the chair this sounds like a personal
problem but my butt hurts so bad um I
tell them and that's pretty much it we
just do a lot of homework cheers to all
the people out there who now know why I
keep telling y'all we should pay
teachers more well what a minute now you
know my running to the next question
Oh what's
best part about being home with the kids
24/7 yes best part of it I'm gonna be
ruling you the smartest move my husband
and I made was bringing our nanny to
Montana with us when we like left LA
because man we're just trying to keep
her safe from the colonel right and also
I knew that my husband would become a
complete cowboy I mean there's ranch
24/7 so Allie our nanny we took her with
us and and the best thing I guess is
because we did that I get a long time
with three kids with us so I get alone
time with them individually and I'm able
to and brain it'll take one and zap is
that rain now
no it's Hale okay cuz it does it sound
like snow okay it's snowing outside it's
really pretty but anyway that was my
feet on the tub in case but anyway so
Ali's been helping really holding it
down helping us with the homework stuff
that's been doing his homework stuff in
a separate have been doing stuff with
Remmy as well our three or even our
exploring minds are Montessori team in
LA they're awesome they've been sitting
really cool stuff for me to be doing
he's smart little kid they're all really
it's so hard though they just don't I
mean they're already cooked inside you
know and like the last thing they're
excited about is math like let's just be
real so that's been that's been in go
that's why I'm drinking and that's why I
was quite drinking biggest life changes
is the biggest life changes I'm gonna be
honestly I don't think we've had this
much off time in a minute we usually
work like a ton so I think the biggest
life changes at work I mean I know this
is horrible what's happening but we we
really needed this as a family I think
just like the family time I was texting
with my makeup artist to weather on a
group
she was like man we're trying to take
advantage of it because she you know
family is we're not home often with each
other Ellen well you know the parents
are working or kids are at school you
see each other in the morning it's a
nice boy they go to bed like it's you
know we're just trying to make them you
know the best out of this situation and
I think we're doing that I have not
cooked this much in my entire life I did
make some killer enchiladas chicken
enchiladas chick what are some cool tips
for keeping the kids busy um we color a
lot we play games guess who is a
favorite clue is a favorite with our 13
year old or Ronnie cue or battleship and
then VR
I cannot believe Steph forgot his VR out
of all people in our household to leave
the VR but I brought mine because I'm
smart and he plays my VR soon as my
five-year-old trusts do it so and we
roast marshmallows about side we do
s'mores luckily I mean we're we're
trapped here but like at the same time
we're trapped in a really beautiful
place so we'll take our kam and the
family will all get in and drive around
our ranch and it's just nice cuz it's
yours was snowing and it's really pretty
and so we're just trying to make the
best of it honestly we're really
fortunate though because I have friends
that are like stuck in apartments and I
totally well I grew up an apartment so I
feel ya and that you can start to feel
stir-crazy so you know we play video
games we do a bunch of stuff watch
movies together and read we read a lot
so what really keeps me happy I like
just together this time baby
you know yeah you want me to keep you in
love with this dancers what really keeps
me happy is my husband situ holding my
this was your idea
what keeps me happy is that what it says
you know what's what really keeps me
happy is this keeps me happy
now having a long time keeps me happy I
think since we're all like you know kind
of stuck it's nice to like trade off
with other adults and like have your
kind of minute to like just like chill
in your own because especially with
toddlers I mean no squareit even
teenagers they're they're not happy
stuck inside you know they just start
becoming sometimes the worst versions of
themselves so what makes me happy is
getting a little a long time and also
like I said getting family time we don't
really get a ton of that because we work
so much so just trying to take advantage
of that your favorite books or book
right now um my favorite one I'm still
reading this man it's a it's kind of a
hard read power versus force it's a book
I've been reading for a minute it's kind
of hot I used to read so much and then
you have kids and there's like so much
time left and it's not a lot so it takes
me forever to read a book especially
like a scientific eOne scientific ii
brought to you by babies a scientific
one oh no it's a it's a really cool book
you should read it
if you it's kind of I'd love to give you
a synopsis but you just have to read it
the dogs are barking yeah go teeth snack
yes my go-to snack is I've been making a
lot of like chicken and steak tacos
because we have I look godless that si
si company because we have all the taco
shells from them and then there's all
many custom of flour tortillas that we I
just stocked up on and so we making you
know we have a lot of like chicken and
steak here so we we make a lot of like
tacos and and it's an easy thing or like
quesadillas or just an easy kind of
thing to go to
and my three-year-old eats a lot of
oatmeal how's your opulence and also
when you go to shows that you're into I
just thought you weren't at the house
and I had a little bit of a lunch time
the kids were sleeping in i watched the
new emma which is so good i mean huge
Jane Austen fan and there's been quite a
few Emma's made this one those really
good
I love the actors I loved all the actors
I loved how they did the storyline
usually emma is like my least favorite
character of genius jane austen's
because she's kind of annoying and
privileged but they did a really good
job actress did a really good job of
really like I don't know showcasing all
the different sides of her and you okay
no coughing but anyway I really love the
new Emma that's really all I've seen
your arm is killing you you can talk
more about your mom
I'm so positive I stay positive I have
to work it's a positive I've suffered
from depression so I've been really
working staying positive a lot of time
and I that's a daily thing for me just
to remind myself the way you how
fortunately am i lucky I am and and you
know we all find all the demons of our
past so I I don't know why every day I
do keep a gratitude journal and I think
that it's important to remind ourselves
even though when you think you are down
and like things are super crappy because
everybody's world is validated
everybody's emotions are relegated in
their own it's all relative but I'm I
don't know I have to really remind
myself of what what should be grateful
Florida especially right now our
family's healthy except for Braden you
just coughed I'm just kidding
and we're safe and that's all you know
especially a parent can ask words so I
don't know I try and focus on the good
I like our lunchtime together my lips
are your lips like show dry no one know
how we're all doing we're all doing good
I think my three-year-old is about to
he's got cabin fever unfortunately for
him he was really sick before all this
happened so he had to be home from
school for like I feel like it was like
two weeks and he was sick of kind of a
week before that and so he he's been
stuck inside for like a good hot second
so and he's three so he's got to be four
oh we're gonna sell whatever his
birthday we're gonna do something really
cool he's gonna turn for April 12 and
probably be here
all right well Brandon's arm is getting
tired and I'd like to be alone in this
bath so all you mom is out there and you
daddies everybody grandmom's whoever's
taking care of kiddos especially y'all
send us your everywhere all in this okay
I know there's good moments but there's
bad moments too and it makes us feel
better when you know we share our
stories so if you have any funny videos
or pictures or whatnot you know put them
up on social media and use the hashtag
hashtag whole not alone get it hashtag
whole not alone I know you get it okay
all right well bye I'm gonna see miss
Chavez till the kids find me bye
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going